[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es eine wunsch rezept von
meinen zuschauern in diesem jahr ist ein
ganz ganz großer cache trend sag ich
jetzt mal einen so ein kuchen und torten
trend hier diese fundorte
beziehungsweise diese frucht orten
ich habe hier einmal einen buchstaben
eine zahl und auch eine schöne herzform
und zwar geht es wirklich gerade im
internet sehr starke rum und ich habe
mir gedacht komm sally macht ein rezept
dazu denn die torten sehen wirklich
super hübsch aus sie passend zu jedem
anlass wie geburtstag hochzeit egal was
für ein feiertag mitbringen soll
muttertag vatertag freundinnen tag
vielleicht doch einfach mal so um
jemanden zu überraschen und die torten
könnt ihr gerne gestalten wie ihr
möchtet ich habe einmal eine version in
herzform mit zwischen rosa abwehr sahne
creme
ich habe eine rainbow torte gemacht und
ich habe hier noch eine etwas elegantere
torte mit mango rosen
ich zeige euch jetzt zuerst einmal
worauf es bei mythic ankommt damit da
nämlich richtig schön die form behält
und stellt euch mal kurz zuvor für den
mürbeteig brauch ich 240 gramm kalte
butter 120 gramm puderzucker einen
viertel teelöffel salz etwas vanille
extrakt 1 1 360 gramm mehl und 120 gramm
gemahlene mandeln
ich gebe es zuerst die kalte butter in
eine schüssel und ihr könnt den teig
jetzt entweder mit den händen verkneten
oder mit der küchenmaschine geht beides
gut er sollte den mann ist lange kneten
oder weg geschickt hatte um möbel
bleiben muss puderzucker umsatz mit rein
und ein bisschen vanille extrakt und wer
möchte kann zum beispiel auch ein
bisschen bittermandel aroma zufügen
zitronenschalen abrieb oder auch gerne
andere aromen und jetzt ganz kurz
verbinden
hier kommt jetzt noch das 1 dazu und
sobald die zutaten verbunden sind noch
mehl und mandeln
[Musik]
jetzt ist der teig gut verbunden und ihr
seht da klebt jetzt ein bisschen
daher werde ich ihn jetzt abdecken und
für eine stunde kühl stellen und zeit
nutze ich um euch zu zeigen wie ich die
schoko version hersteller bei der schoko
version ersetzt sich einfach 50 gramm
mehl durch 50 km kakaopulver
[Musik]
jetzt ist der teig schön kalt und ich
habe ihn einmal nochmal durchgeknetet
damit ich ihnen schon auf rollen kann
wichtig ist dass er jetzt gleichmäßig
ausgerollt wird damit die platte auch
gleichmäßig backen kann nämlich ein
bisschen mehr
und diese teig hölzer und werdet den
teig 5 mm dick ausrollen
[Musik]
hier könnte einfach mal mit einer
palette darunter dann klebt der teig
nicht an der unterlage aus diesem tag
schneidig ist entweder zwei buchstaben
aus zwei zahlen oder auch formen
je nachdem was jeden zubereiten möchte
und die habe ich mir bereits aus papier
als schablone ausgedruckt und
ausgeschnitten damit ich gleich beim
umsetzen jetzt den teig dann nicht
verformen kann ich ihnen jetzt schon mal
auf die back folie stürzen einfach mit
hilfe von seinem torten retter
[Musik]
und damit ich die back wohl jetzt nicht
zerstören nämlich einfach ein stumpfes
messer
die schablone könnt ihr auch gerne
selbst basteln dafür könnt ihr euch
einen buchstaben oder eine zahl
ausdrucken im din a4 format und das
ganze dann auf jeden fall 6 cm breit
ausschneiden
[Musik]
der erste ist fertig den zweiten rolle
und schneide ich jetzt auch aus und
bevor der jetzt in den backofen kommt
muss ich eben für etwa eine halbe stunde
einfrieren damit er beim backen einfach
nichts mehr läuft
[Musik]
jetzt sind alle kekse würden gebacken
und herzig komplett abkühlen lassen
jetzt kommt die creme rein
ich verwende jetzt eine frisch käsecreme
weil ich finde dass sie wirklich
supergut dazu fasst ihr könnt aber auch
zum beispiel in der quark oder auch eine
mascarpone creme nehmen ich verwende
jetzt für die frisch käsecreme etwas
frisch käse sahne sabbath puderzucker
und vanille extrakt dafür frühere ich
jetzt den frischkäse mit dem vanille
extrakt und puderzucker in eine schüssel
füge die sahne ganz langsam dazu
zum schluss kommt sonderfahrt mit rein
und so wird die creme steif geschlagen
[Musik]
jetzt startet mit der ersten variation
mit dem herz und dafür nehme ich jetzt
die erste creme da könnt ihr einfach mal
bei meinen wind wollten vorbeischauen da
habe ich nämlich eine richtig tolle
frucht frischkäse creme und die habe ich
jetzt in einem spritzbeutel hier vorne
mit einer großen loch töne und es wird
wirklich immer am schönsten aus und
damit spritze ich jetzt hier diese dutt
vertraut
[Musik]
wie lege ich den zweiten kicks
vorsichtig drauf und da kommt jetzt die
zweite creme schicht drauf
[Musik]
und jetzt könnt ihr hier das topping
eurer wahl drauf machen
ich habe es hier ein paar erdbeeren
himbeeren ihr könnt auch blüten
verwenden die man entweder mit essen
kann oder blüten die einfach ungespritzt
sind und nur zur deko denen schön finde
ich auch immer bsc trotzig habe jetzt
diese bei seedorf selber gemacht ihr
könnt ihr natürlich auch fertig kaufen
hier könnt ihr mal in meinen basics
nachschauen da habe ich das grundrezept
schon online
dafür wird nämlich eiweiß mit etwas salz
und zucker aufgeschlagen und zwar so
lange bis keine zuckerkristalle mehr
zwischen den fingern zu spüren sind
anschließend könnt ihr das wie sie dann
in verschiedenen farben einfärben dafür
eignen sich lebensmittel verpassten am
besten
[Musik]
mit verschiedenen spritzten spritzt sich
dann die b c masse auf ein backblech mit
backpapier oder back folie
[Musik]
und so werden sie dann im ofen
getrocknet je nach backofen will ihr
dann umluft oder heißluft etwa 90 bis
100 grad so dass die b c masse keine
farbe bekommt und da werden sie so lange
getrocknet bis man sie mit den fingern
vom backblech runter bewegen kann und
ganz schön finde ich auch immer macarons
und die sätze ich jetzt hier einfach
irgendwie schön drauf
[Musik]
war jetzt schon 1 ist fertig und jetzt
kommen noch den nächsten fall
[Musik]
aus der mango mache ich jetzt kleine
manko hosen dafür wird die mango mit
einem sparschäler geschält und jetzt
schneidig rechts und links vom kern das
fruchtfleisch herunter und schneidet
dieses in dünne scheiben
[Musik]
jetzt wird die erste wagen gescheiter
als spirale auf die torte gelegt und
drei bis vier scheiben lege ich noch
außen herum
[Musik]
und so sehen jetzt meine drei
variationen aus ich finde sie echt cool
vor allem die mainboard horte was
natürlich cool aus wichtig ist halt dass
er wirklich früchte der sorgt nehmen
könnte
ja wir bis heute ähnlich sagt auf alle
als wäre alles genommen was es im
supermarkt gab auch wenn gerade keine
erdbeerzeit genau also ganz ehrlich
erklärt könnte wirklich verzichten
ihr habt macht es wirklich wenn ihr
weniger in einem sommer damit dem im
sommer dann gar nicht einmal so will
eigentlich ist blöd da müsste man ja
aber er wollte unbedingt dass ich das
mache also hab ich gemacht dennoch
versteht selbst sei nicht nachtragend
wir machen das damit jedes sieht was
alles möglich ist zwar meine abschneiden
ich denke im anschluss sehen sind nicht
mehr so ganz toll auf die kekse sind ja
ziemlich hart aber wir probieren sondern
vor allem auch gut für eine goldene
hochzeit zum beispiel mal genau auf ein
kraut sogar auch von trauer tag der
hochzeit oder 50 stadtgeburtstag es geht
sogar mal ganz gut unterscheiden also
kariert kreativ sein möchte er was du
machen musst um 18 merklichen markierung
ist jetzt das ist mal zeit habe ich ja
schon jetzt einfach den bc ja tut mir
leid lassen wir sie schmeckt einfach 6,3
sie sparen sich elektronen creme spricht
ich leg dich nicht zu süß ja ich lebe
frischkäse grad noch ein bisschen weiter
probieren und wo es eher stoff wie sie
zwischen rangemacht nein das ist und
falls ihr die rezepte ausprobieren
möchtet viele dsl blog.de ich freue mich
schon auf eure kreationen je nachdem ob
er einen buchstaben reform oder auch
eine legal macht schickt uns ein foto
bzw markiert und sagt instagram oder
facebook er versteht nicht wann ich die
abmoderation macht erich honecker nach
800 wie das muss man das noch nicht
verstehen
ich wünsche euch viel spaß und
nachbacken die noch im guten appetit
schon mal die bohnen gegessen und bis
zum nächsten mal schießt ich meine
großen willst dann versteht er dass ich
fertig bin
wahnsinn der bogen
[Musik]